Chicago officials hope to win a bid for
Amazon's second headquarters which might
launch them into the top tier of tech
friendly cities so given that why on
earth would Chicago's mayor proposed a
tax on startups like lyft and uber it
seems sort of anti tech I mean I get the
basic reason it's a way of raising
revenue for the city's public transit
system it's becoming a vicious cycle
public transit problems boost uber and
lyft to the detriment of public transit
but atching successful startups to prop
up failing transit systems isn't what's
best for tech or what's best for
consumers indeed some other cities are
already finding value in cutting public
transit and said subsidizing
ride-sharing a better approach would be
to embrace new innovations at all
transit sectors as uber responded after
the taxes proposed
when safe and affordable rides are
available across every neighborhood
whether by bus train or ride share
Chicagoans can get to their jobs or
family obligations without having to own
a car do you think government
regulations are too tough on tech let us
know in your comments also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI